>>Dana: My name's Dana and I'm nine.
And my favorite thing of technology
is my dad's iPhone 'cause it has lots
of games on it.
When I first got my computer,
I was very, very excited.
When I was seven.
And I love the internet,
so I kept on going on it.
>>I love this picture.
>>Allison: Dana's a
very special girl.
She comes from Kazakhstan.
Both she and her sister, we adopted.
>>Dana: My dad giving
me my first toy.
And then my dad signing
the contract [singing].
>>Allison: She is a child of song
and from the moment she wakes up,
to the moment she goes to
sleep, if she's not talking,
she's humming, she's singing.
>>Dana: [singing] For
our health, our homes,
our families, for the precious gift--
>>Allison: Her father and her mother
have something to do with technology,
and so she's always
had the stuff around.
But it's always been around
as if it's been furniture.
It's not, you know,
this special thing.
She's using technology
as a digital native,
as immersed because it's there.
>>Dana: This is the pet of the month.
It's called Doogal.
>>Dana: You can just buy them.
It has a special tag and you can
log its code onto the website,
and then you'll see your animal.
You can name it.
>>Personally, I have twenty one.
You have to feed it, you
have to take care of it,
you have to go playwith it every
single day, or else it will die.
And that takes about an hour.
About to change sites 'cause
also like to go on PBS Kids Co.
>>Allison: She happens to adore PBS.
>>Dana: You can make your player
here, just by doing anything
that you want really, and
then I can change their shirts
and their hair [inaudible].
>>Allison: But she's a kid that
just happens to go to the places
that are suitable for her,
and we have conversations
about what's appropriate
and what's not.
>>Dana: So I'm supposed to hump
and try to get all these candies,
and when I fill up, I go
busing through the house.
Oh, and red light means I have
to be careful, 'cause mom's going
to come soon, so I have to get down.
So I'm pushing my luck here.
Look out, mom's coming.
>>Ben: We have a general
guideline, which is, be responsible
and do stuff that's appropriate.
And if you find yourself on a
place that's not appropriate,
just shut it down.
If you're kind of interested,
but you're not sure, come ask us
and we'll come talk to you and
you'll never get in trouble.
>>All: [playing bells]
>>Allison: The children that
are digital natives today are
still children.
They are children who love stories.
>>Teacher: Mine looks like a clown.
>>Allison: They are children
who wanna be respected.
>>Here's kind of his little
forehead, and that's his little hat.
>>Allison: They are children
that wanna love learning.
>>Female: But I do know that.
I'm talking about like
the double digit.
>>Allison: They don't
just wanna search.
They wanna use what they've searched
for and do something with it.
They wanna be creative.
They are probably more
digitally native
at home than they are in school.
They should be allowed
to pursue their passions.
>>Dana: Remember that?
>>Jari: I do.
>>That's probably here.
>>In the winter, when
you were a little older?
>>Jari: Having Dana show me where
she has a personal website and go
through her photos, it's
an extension of self.
And we have to be able to figure
out how to let technology have
that ability for kids to
individualize who they are and bring
who they are to the school.
>>Allison: And so what number
sentence helped you with that?
>>Dana: Thirteen.
>>Jari: For Dana, 'cause she has
some interesting learning challenges,
it provides an easy access for
her to be able to get information
down in writing, or to
organize her thinking visually,
and that really helps
and supports her.
>>What do you think
about this keyboard?
Can you type an actual
sentence on there-- ?
>>Dana: It's way too small.
>>What do you think
would be ideal for you?
>>Dana: Slide it out.
>>Slide it out?
All right, try this one.
>>Allison: What happens at Kids
Team, two afternoons a week
and two weeks during the
summer is that we help
to make new technologies
better for kids.
>>We work with mostly is the
National Park Service a lot.
ome of their games on their
website are sorta cheesy,
so we are the people who
like fix it up and stuff.
>>Mona: The kids are
our design partners.
They absolutely have as many
good ideas as the big people do.
The children are experts
in being children,
and even though we were all children
once, we weren't children in 2009.
Sometimes we'll take a look at an
existing technology, for instance,
People in Need, which is a website
that supports people in need
in Haiti, and is looking to try
and support more interaction
between children.
>>Dana: And so you can click
on one of these families.
It says, "Learn more.
Help this family."
And so it tells you a
little bit about it.
>>Allison: Actually, the
favorite technique of all
of our children is what the
kids call bags of stuff,
but the adults call
low tech prototyping.
And what we do is, we
take bags of art supplies
and we start to build things.
>>Woman: Now what do we
need the microphone for?
>>You can also do like a video chat.
>>Dana: Sometimes people
ask, "Help me do this,"
or sometimes it will just be a
"Choose whatever you
wanna do sort of thing."
I guess you just use the computer
all the time in your brain.
And then we all come together
and we explain what we did.
>>So I thought you should be
able to send stuff to the people.
>>So it was streamlining
the video taking process.
We also talked about making
it easy to add pictures too.
>>You can just put the
camera on your computer
and then you can do the video.
>>Good work, all right [applause].
>>Dana: [singing] For our
health, our homes, our families,
for the precious gift of sight.
>>Lisa: So the way I want you
to use this video at home,
after you've practiced with me.
>>Lisa: Video work and the
internet are the next big wave
of how we're trying to reach
out to teens and youth,
to pull them into the
Jewish music scene,
either by teaching via the internet,
conferencing via the internet,
connecting in so many different
ways through videos and music.
So that's how she got sucked into it.
>>Dana: [singing] Generations of
community, united hearts and souls
and they all shall dream dream,
and you shall see visions.
And our hopes will rise to the sky.
>>Lisa: Excellent, awesome.
>>Allison: We have to understand
that literacy is just not about text,
and it's even not just
about what's visual.
It's about the combination of the
visual, the oral, the interactivity
and being able to support
children in all different ways.
The technology is a way to do it,
so you don't need the
gifted teacher all the time.
You can get a kid with passion at
home doing the things, and then going
into school and saying,
"Look, look what I've done."
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org